[Music]
Avengers endgame has just released
worldwide so in anticipation for it I
decided to go back and watch the Marvel
movies in chronological order from
beginning to end in order to rank them
from worst to best this is the fifth
time that I've done it and I absolutely
love revisiting the film's at the added
context of the sequels and Easter eggs
throughout this video I'll be going
through each film one by one to let you
know how it compares to the rest and why
I think of it this list covers all 22
films including endgame so it should
give you an overall idea of how good or
bad that film is without the way
I'm your host definition thank you for
clicking the video now let's dive into
my list of the 22 MCU movies ranked from
worst to best Thor Thor comes last on
the list for a number of reasons firstly
the film feels slightly by-the-numbers
with a portrayal of Thor that's
difficult to connect with the dialogue
feels overly Shakespearean which if you
know of Kenneth Branagh who directed the
film is expected it just doesn't feel
fitting for the MCU the piece is cliched
and due to its pacing it feels slightly
disjointed and its third act is very
underdeveloped if someone was to judge
Thorpe euerle up this film alone and now
for a fact that many would not hold the
character as the fan favorite that he is
now overall it feels very underwhelming
and that's why it holds last place the
Incredible Hulk
when going through a watch of the MCU
The Incredible Hulk definitely feels
like the most unnecessary out the film's
the origin story is skipped over mainly
due to the Hulk film that covered it a
couple of years prior and Bar General
Ross nothing from this film really gets
touched upon in the height of films the
action CGI and plot elements all feel
slightly dated by today's standards and
this movie hasn't held up in the way
that say Iron Man did overall it's
totally fine however due to the quality
of the other films on this list it's
hard to rank it any higher
Captain Marvel Captain Marvel sees the
first female at film in the Marvel
Universe and showcases the origin story
for Carol Danvers aka Captain
unfortunately for me the film feels a
bit flat and lacks the wit and ingenuity
of the other Marvel movies whilst the
scrolls twist was surprising and samuel
l.jackson steals the show brie Larson
falls a bit flat for me due to her lack
of charisma and aloofness Iron Man 2
Iron Man 2 had some pretty big shoes or
should I say suits to fell and not to
give anything away but its predecessor
it's one of my favorite comic book films
ever made and this one falls flat in
almost every department when compared to
it the arc for Tony isn't as strong the
villains are both underdeveloped and
don't really put up much of a challenge
and whilst there's a nice metaphor for
the gun control debate with the
government tried to strip Tony of its
right to bear weapons it feels slightly
meandering even the normally outstanding
Scarlett Johansson feels pedestrian here
and overall it's just a bit
underwhelming Thor the dark world
thought the dark world is a real guilty
pleasure of mine
whilst it's hated by many I absolutely
loved the film
it's got fast paced action some great
twists and it also makes Thor far more
likable than he was in the first film
whilst the bill is pretty underdeveloped
this is Loki's moment to shine and he
secures himself as a fan favorite based
purely of this film Captain America the
First Avenger
whilst Captain America the First Avenger
is often overlooked I actually really
enjoy the film due to its heart message
and period saying the movie beautifully
portrays what it takes to be a hero and
excellently interweaves the propaganda
aspect of the character that was
prevalent throughout the Second World
War
add to that the ever so catchy song
star-spangled man and the villainous Red
Skull and you have a hit on your hands
that's my second favorite origin story
from phase one high in man three Iron
Man 3 is actually a guilty pleasure of
mine luckily or unluckily depending on
how you look at it I had the big twist
from this film spoiled for me months
before I saw it so I didn't find it that
jarring I can see the bad in it but due
to the performances of Downey Don
Cheadle and more I really have a great
time whilst watching it the Air Force
One rescue scene is incredible and one
of the best action set pieces in a
Marvel movie and a completely fanboy out
over the bow
with all the versions of the suits the
film really secures Iron Man as the
coolest character for me and whilst the
script may not be the best there is
definitely a lot of fun to be had here
oh yeah and it's a Christmas movie
ant-man and the wasp ant-man in the
wasps may not live up to the first film
in my eyes but it's still a lot of fun
and upon its release it felt like the
perfect palette cleanser for the events
of infinity war this really takes the
character in a new direction and the
house arrest motif that constantly sees
Scott battling between helping his
friends or seeing his daughter isn't
it's by a choice the film uses San
Francisco to full effect and also has
one of the coolest looking villain
costumes ever put to film with the
design of the ghost this doesn't really
possess the stakes of the other films
but it's still an enjoyable ride that
showcases the dexterity of the MCU
Doctor Strange Doctor Strange brings
magic to the MCU with a spellbinding
tale about the titular characters
journey of enlightenment whilst the
initial hour of the film is slightly
derivative of Batman Begins it takes a
complete 180 and bench's into untried
territory that is laden with outstanding
effects and a unique final showdown
overall Doctor Strange is a fun ride but
I find it's slightly too formulaic to
scratch the upper echelon of the MCU and
that's why I gets a position here
guardians of the galaxy - depending on
what day it is guardians - jumps back
and forth with the first film as my
favorite out of the two however during
this watch through I actually prefer the
first film over it that's not to say
it's bad though and this is an
incredible second outing for the
characters nebula becomes a massively
likable antihero
and this father and son story really
delivers on a lot of levels what's not
to love about an adventure with baby
Groot
guardians of the galaxy guardians of the
galaxy is by far one of the funnest
films in the franchise it took the cast
of characters from the Zed list and was
a huge risk for Marvel that paid off
massively not only does it set up the
space side of the saga it also builds
upon several elements of the MCU such as
an appearance by Thanos Ronan the
accuser the collector and infinite
guardians is a movie with a lot of heart
and it's one of my favorites Avengers
age of Ultron Avengers age of Ultron
gets a pretty bad rap in my opinion the
film is one of the most developed bills
out of the saga and this movie
beautifully puts cracks in the
relationships of the team that would
come to fruition in civil war the
Hulkbuster fight is outstanding and one
of the best action scenes in the series
whilst it doesn't match up to the first
Avengers film and isn't really trying to
and that's what a lot of people get
confused I really enjoy even to this day
and that's why it ranks higher than most
ant-man ant-man took an absurd hero and
show that Marvel had the ability to make
even the most obscure name a mainstream
hit the film is full of fun from
beginning to end and it tells the story
of a father on the wrong side of the law
tried to do good by his daughter add to
that the comedic delivery of Paul Rudd
and he have a small hero that makes a
big impact on the list black panther
black panther was groundbreaking in many
ways not only did it completely reinvent
the africa aesthetic it also did it in a
way that made it seem mystical and Peter
istic this was the first time that we
really saw a Marvel hero lose and the
arc of kill manga is just as fascinating
as the movie's protagonist it's no
wonder that this film got nominated for
Best Picture when it's this good
spider-man homecoming
spider-man homecoming not only works as
a fantastic coming-of-age story but it's
also the most accurate story on the
webhead
to ever be released this is a fun-filled
ride from start to finish that beaches a
knockout performance by Michael Keaton
as the vulture and Tom Holland is Peter
Parker add to that the mentoring that
Tony Stark provides and you really get a
fleshed out film that makes you a
friendly neighborhood spider-man slop
perfectly into the MCU Captain America
the Winter Soldier Captain America the
Winter Soldier was when the MC you've
got serious his political espionage
thriller is far advanced beyond its
years and really feels like a grounded
and great take on
is that our in it the movie expertly
tackles privacy terrorism and the
government in an adult manner that is
still fun to watch this movie too has a
heart and that's why it stands out as
one of the best films in the franchise
or Ragnarok Thor Ragnarok totally
reinvents the titular character and puts
him in a hilarious film that is far
removed from the original movie at this
point Thor had become a fan favorite and
this film cements him as one of the best
Avengers all of the supporting cast
really put their a-game and the movie
introduces Korg to the world who's
probably the funnest MCU character ever
created add to that the inspiration from
Planet Hulk the destruction of Asgard
and an amazing performance by Jeff
Goldblum and he had one of the best MCU
movies ever made
Iron Man Iron Man kicked off the MCU in
spectacular fashion
this film had to be a success for Marvel
in order to start their grand vision and
there was a lot riding on its shoulders
however due to perfect casting
outstanding CGI expert pacing and a
relatable protagonist that turned a
scoundrel into a hero the movie
succeeded in several ways it's one of my
favorite origin stories of all time that
ranks up there with Batman Begins and
it's brilliant from start to finish the
piece works as an outstanding 9/11 and
Iraq war metaphor with an arms dealer
having to handle the repercussions of
arming the Middle East terrorists to the
point that they were able to hit back
even today it stands as an amazing piece
of cinema and that's why it easily
secures a spot in the top 5 The Avengers
The Avengers changed the landscape of
film and heralded in a new generation of
shared movie universes that all failed
to match up to this first instance in
the industry from beginning to end the
movie encapsulates the comics and feels
like an outstanding Beijing brought to
life on the big screen overnight this
turn its heroes from being c-listers to
the most profitable comic book
characters on earth whether it's the
incredibly way dialogue provided by Joss
Whedon or phenomenal action in the city
of New York everything feels like it's
innovating while setting the bar high
enough that many would fail to live up
to
every hero is fully fleshed out and
developed and this is the perfect team
of film from beginning to end that on
any given day depending on what mood
you're in could be considered the best
in the franchise Captain America Civil
War verses movies are 10 a penny and
often they're pretty lackluster Civil
War however is a shining example of how
to do it right in the same year that saw
the release of Batman V Superman Civil
War managed to perfectly capture what a
rivalry of this scale should be like
while it's adding the heart that its
competitors sorely missed the movie is
epic from start to finish
and contains many devastating moments
such as the death of Peggy Carter the
reveal at the Winter Soldier murder the
Starks and the collapse of the Avengers
add to that the introduction of
spider-man black panther and the seminal
airport sequence and you have one of the
best superhero movies of all time
phenomenal from start to finish
Civil War deserves its spark in the top
three films Avengers infinity war in my
head before seeing infinity war I
thought that there was no way that this
could live up to the hype Danis had been
teased for 10 years as had the Infinity
stones and with almost every character
from the franchise in the film
it just seemed impossible for the Russo
brothers to pull it off however against
all odds they managed to infinity war is
a complete masterpiece that possesses
perfect pacing outstanding action scenes
but also an unforgettable ending that
will arguably stand as one of the
greatest twists ever put to film for a
long time infinity war not only nails
everything that hit attempts but it also
surpasses all the expectations and
creates an outstanding movie from
beginning to end that showcases why the
MCU is the most popular film franchise
of all time this is a complete
masterpiece and deserves its position
here
list Avengers endgame Avengers endgame
rightfully deserves its spot at number
one on this list as it's absolutely
incredible from start to finish
the movie has outstanding action but
also packs emotional punches that will
have you laughing with joy in some parts
and crying in others this is the perfect
send-off for every character in the
entire MCU and honestly if this was the
final film in the franchise it would
feel like one of the best send offs of
all time this movie not only is the best
on this list but it's also the best
comic book film ever made and that's why
it secures the number1 spot so what's
your list and where do you rank Avengers
end game cop it below and let me know
and if you enjoy this video then make
sure you check out my ending explain
breakdown on the latest MCU film which
you blinked at the end this is a channel
for people who are super into
superheroes so if that's the kind of
thing you like it subscribe thanks again
to take the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you